now one of the most prominent
republicans doing this
is megan mccain on the view and i'm i'm
not gonna
uh beat up on megan mccain for calling
for the impeachment
mainly because donald trump was very
mean to her dad and so i i get it you
know i sort of understand
why she might not like the guy but
listen listen to megan's argument
as to why we need to impeach the former
president donald trump
i'm a lifelong conservative unlike a lot
of these heretics i mean i was
born into this raised into it it's my
whole entire life
and in all ways and i truly at the
bottom of my soul i think as all of you
know i
i believe in the principles i was raised
on it is very difficult for me to come
on this show right now because i've
always prided myself on having my finger
on the tenor of what's going on in
conservative circles even when i didn't
agree with trump i
i you know i'm not a squoosh i'm not
someone who went full brainwashed
lincoln project that everything that's
conservative is a
bastion of evil and i must reject it and
atone myself
i'm not that kind of republican or
conservative but right now i cannot
defend this i believe president trump
should be impeached
i believe we have to take a stand and
have a fine line about
what is acceptable for a president to do
or not he incited a riot
people got violent people died full stop
okay so as i said i'm not i'm not gonna
go after really the the substance here
because uh you know if trump were
were as tough on my father as he was on
megan's father
maybe i'd feel differently about the man
uh obviously megan mccain and i disagree
on on impeachment
and uh and i suppose on trump more
broadly but i want to focus in on
on one word she said president
president she said it's very important
to impeach president
trump there is no president trump
president trump is gone there is former
president trump
and sometimes in this country we refer
to former presidents as president
but we're actually not supposed to as a
matter of etiquette
you really shouldn't refer to former
presidents as mr president
or president bush or president clinton
because there's only one president
there's only and it's it actually does
get to we we do it to be polite i've
i've done it myself
but as a matter of republican virtue
lower case r there's only one president
at one time there's only one
governor at one time you really
shouldn't
we to be polite we sometimes say you
know governor huntsman or governor
pataki but really you shouldn't there's
only one
and the constitution does not establish
a process to impeach ex-presidents
just to impeach the president that is
why by the way
at this alleged impeachment trial the
chief justice is not going to preside
the chief justice only presides
according to the constitution
at an impeachment trial when you impeach
the president
but we're not unless unless it's a bait
and switch and this whole thing is just
cocaine mitch's big ruse to convince
democrats that they're impeaching trump
but then
accidentally they end up impeaching
biden that would be hilarious and i
wouldn't put him past mr cocaine he is a
slippery one
but unless that happens chief justice
can't be there
now you might say well michael we've
we've impeached ex-judges before
that which is true there we talked about
this a little bit on on the verdict
podcast with senator cruz
there have been times that that
ex-officials have been impeached
according to various laws
but the president is no ordinary
official an impeachment trial in the
senate is no ordinary impeachment
it is laid out the process is laid out
explicitly in the u.s
constitution and the constitution
provides
no route to impeach a former president
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you